♪ ♪
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, WE ARE
HERE TONIGHT IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA FOR OUR
EXCLUSIVE INTERVIEW WITH
CAITLYN JENNER, RUNNING TO BE
THE NEXT GOVERNOR OF THE GREAT
STATE OF CALIFORNIA, TO REPLACE
GAVIN NEWSOM.
LET ME JUST ASK YOU ABOUT LAW
AND ORDER.
WE WATCHED THE RIOTS THIS
SUMMER.
SOME DEMOCRATS AND MEDIA PEOPLE
WOULDN'T ACKNOWLEDGE THEY ARE
RIOTS.
I HAVE STATISTICS IN L.A., 465
SHOOTINGS SINCE JANUARY 1ST, UP
67% FROM LAST YEAR.
HOMICIDES UP 26%.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT L.A. COUNTY, AE
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES, WELL,
HOMICIDES UP A WHOPPING 113%,
AND GAVIN NEWSOM IS GOING TO
RELEASE 76,000 ADDITIONAL
INMATES FOR GOOD BEHAVIOR,
63,000 OF THEM COMMITTED VIOLENT
CRIMES.
WOULD YOU DO THAT?
>> Caitlyn: NOT AT ALL.
I THINK, ON THE RELEASING OF THE
PRISONERS, CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM IS VERY IMPORTANT.
AND WE NEED TO DO THAT, OKAY?
WE NEED TO REHABILITATE PEOPLE
IN PRISON AND BRING THEM BACK
INTO THE COMMUNITY SAFELY.
IN HIS CASE, I DON'T KNOW HOW
MANY OF THESE PEOPLE HAVE
ACTUALLY BEEN REHABILITATED TO
GO BACK INTO SOCIETY.
AND SO, I AM 100% BEHIND OUR
POLICE FORCE.
EVERY PLACE I GO, IF I SEE A
COP, IF I'M DRIVING AND I SEE A
COP, I WILL PUT MY HAND OUT THE
WINDOW AND GIVE HIM A THUMBS UP.
IF THEY ARE SITTING THERE, I
WILL PULL OFF AND SAY "HEY,
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE.
THIS CITIZEN APPRECIATES WHAT
YOU DO."
I 100% SUPPORT OUR POLICE
FORCES.
AS FAR AS I WOULD BE VERY TOUGH
ON RIOTING.
USING AS MANY FORCES AS I COULD
POSSIBLY USED TO STOP THE
RIOTING AND PROTECT THE CITIZENS
AND THE BUSINESSES OF THIS
COMMUNITY.
I THINK THAT'S EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT TO.
THE NATIONAL GUARD, WHATEVER WE
NEED TO KEEP PEACE.
>> Sean: WHAT IS THE POLICE
REFORM THAT YOU WANT?
>> Caitlyn: THE ONLY POLICE
REFORM I THINK WE NEED, OKAY,
EVERY BUSINESS OUT THERE,
THERE'S GOOD PEOPLE AND THERE'S
BAD PEOPLE WHO PROBABLY
SHOULDN'T BE THERE, NO MATTER IF
YOU'RE A JOURNALIST, OKAY, NO
MATTER WHAT THE BUSINESS IS --
>> Sean: THE MOM AND THE
MEDIA.
'S GO-AHEAD.
>> Caitlyn: NO MATTER WHAT IT
IS, YOU'RE GOING TO GET GOOD AND
BAD.
I THINK PROPER TRAINING, TO WEED
OUT THE GOOD AND THE BAD, I HAVE
A VERY GOOD FRIEND OF MINE WHO
WAS IN THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT
FOR YEARS, AND WE TALK A LOT
ABOUT THIS ISSUE.
AND I WAS TALKING THE OTHER DAY
ABOUT IT, AND HE SAID YOU
KNOW THE SAD PART IS?
THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT
TRAINING CENTER IS LIKE, ALMOST
EMPTY.
NOBODY WANTS TO BE A COP
ANYMORE.
>> Sean: DO YOU BLAME THEM?
AFTER ALL --
>> Caitlyn: I DO NOT BLAME
THEM.
FROM SACRAMENTO, THAT HAS TO
CHANGE.
>> Sean: THIS IS IMPORTANT.
HOW DO YOU CHANGE THAT?
IN OTHER WORDS, FOR EXAMPLE, I
WOULD SUGGEST MORE TRAINING.
>> Caitlyn: OH, YEAH.
>> Sean: I WOULD LOOK FOR MORE
NONLETHAL OPTIONS, I THINK WOULD
BE A GOOD IDEA, BUT THE FUNDING
DISMANTLING, MY QUESTION TO PEOO
CALL?
>> Caitlyn: I TOTALLY AGREE.
IT IS JUST A STUPID IDEA.
AGAIN, NO COMMON SENSE IN
SACRAMENTO.
GAVIN NEWSOM, NO COMMON SENSE.
TO RELEASE PRISONERS INTO THE
COMMUNITY AND THEN SAY THEY ARE
GOING TO DEFUND THE POLICE.
I SUPPORT THE POLICE 100%.
I SUPPORT THE NATIONAL GUARD.
I SUPPORT OUR BUSINESS OWNERS IN
LOS ANGELES AND AROUND THE
COUNTRY.
AND WOULD DO EVERYTHING I CAN TO
PROTECT THEM.
>> Sean: WE HAVE OTHER ISSUES.
FOR EXAMPLE, GAVIN NEWSOM TALKS
ABOUT TAXING WATER.
I DID A SHOW FROM SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY.
>> Caitlyn: [LAUGHS]
>> Sean: JUST DOING MY
RESEARCH.
>> Caitlyn: I KNOW.
>> Sean: THE DELTA SMELT
PRESENTED FARMERS FROM BEING
ABLE TO FARM.
NOT A SMALL -- FARMS NOW.
>> Caitlyn: I HEARD ABOUT THE
DELTA SMELT.
WATER IS A BIG ISSUE IN THE
STATE.
TO BE HONEST WITH YOU, JUST AS A
RESIDENT, I FOLLOW HOW MUCH
SNOWFALL WE HAVE COME IN EVERY
YEAR I SEE THIS GUY GO OUT, AND
HE IS ON THE NEWS, AND HE HAS
THIS BIG LONG POLE, AND HE TAKES
IT OUT OF THIS FIELD AND STICKS
IT DOWN TO SEE HOW MUCH SNOW WE
HAVE.
THIS YEAR, IT WAS ONLY DOWN,
MAYBE, THREE OR 4 FEET.
OTHER YEARS, IT HAS BEEN TEN OR
20 FEET, PUSHING THE POLE,
YOU THINK WE ARE IN GOOD SHAPE.
OUR WATER SYSTEM IS GOING DOWN
ALL THE TIME.
THIS YEAR, WE ARE DOWN.
YOU'RE IN THE LOS ANGELES AREA,
WE'VE GOT PROBABLY ONLY TWO GOOD
RAINFALLS.
AND YOU CAN SEE THAT FROM MY
HOUSE, YOU CAN SEE HOW
VEGETATION IS VERY, IT IS NOT
GREEN.
IT JUST HASN'T GOT MUCH WATER.
WE ARE HEADED FOR A DROUGHT.
THAT HAS TO BE LOOKED AT IN
ADVANCE.
HERE'S MY CRAZY THINKING.
AGAIN, SEAN, LOGICAL THINKING.
WE ARE NOW SPENDING BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS ON THIS HIGH-SPEED RAIL.
OKAY?
THEY TALK ABOUT IT ALL THE TIME,
BETWEEN L.A. AND SAN FRANCISCO.
AND I'M GOING, WHY ARE WE DOING
THAT?
I CAN GET ON A PLANE AT LAX AND
I WILL BE IN SAN FRANCISCO IN 5.
YOU KNOW, WHY DO WE NEED
HIGH-SPEED RAIL?
WHY DON'T WE DO THIS?
WHY DON'T WE INVEST THAT MONEY
IN DESALINATION PLANTS ALONG THE
COAST?
TAKE THAT WATER, AND ANY TIME IT
IS A BAD YEAR, DESALINATE THE
WATER, HAVE SOME PIPES GOING ON
THE MOUNTAINS TO SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY, THE FARMERS, THE
CAMARILLO AREA, YOU LOOK OVER
HERE, I DRIVE THROUGH THE FARM
YARDS EVERY YEAR, WHY DON'T WE
JUST START TO LOOK AT, WAIT A
SECOND, MAYBE WATER IS A BIGGER
ISSUE THAN TRYING TO MOVE A FEW
PEOPLE --
>> Sean: B